And I searched the blog for info and found info and products in your store for the recipe.
Is it safe to assume that taking collagen is safe for all cancer patients?
I would say no. I think this question was asked last week or the week before this collagen
saved for cancer. And the answer is yes and no. So it depends on where you are with your cancer.
Your cancer is very active and growing. I would say no. You want to be you want to be overly
concerned with any possible growth risk factors. If your cancer is currently at bay and it's really
hasn't done much and I really would like to take some collagen from my hair or skin or nails,
I would say there's nothing wrong with taking collagen. There is one caveat on collagen is that
it isn't that uncommon to have antibodies against collagen. So I also see a number of people
with autoimmune disorders and we test in the Syrex Array 5. One of the things that that tests for
is antibodies, the test for antibodies to a number of different self tissues and one of the
self tissues that a test for is collagen. And it's not that uncommon to have antibodies to collagen.
So that's what could give a person a lot of joint pain. You know, you hear about people with
Lyme disease that have, you know, joint pain that moves around and you hear people with arthritis
and they have joint pain and they think because they have a diagnosis of rheumatoid arthritis or
psoriatic arthritis or even degenerative arthritis that it's because of the
the arthritis meeting, the joint itself that they have pain. But many times when you do
an antibody test, they may actually have rheumatoid factor as well, but they may have antibodies to
collagen. So where's collagen found in your body and found in your joint capsules and found
in your ligaments, your tendons, it's found in any connective tissue, which is good to say because
that's everywhere. So it's like one of the worst thing is to have antibodies against because
you know, when your immune system will flare, you could have pain literally anywhere.
So like I said, with a lot of Lyme patients, the Lyme is the bacteria is long gone,
but what it left them was antibodies to self tissue. And if it's antibodies to collagen,
they can get these weird pains anywhere. So they do anything and step off the kerbrog or their
D feels like it's broken. So if you have any type of symptoms like that, we wear collagen. So those
people, if you do have antibodies to collagen, you can't take exogenous collagen, you're just going
to make things way worse. But while I take collagen before, it's never made me feel worse,
well, then I think you're safe. So then you fall into the category and my cancer's kind of at bay,
you know, it's not growing or anything. I feel like I'm doing well and I just want to
freeze my nails and my skin and my feel better with my joints. Then I don't think there's anything wrong.
We'll take it. But just be aware of that.